on this episode I talk top line bottom
line my dad's shoes and poopoo toes law
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
you're watching episode 15 of the
askgaryvee show fun fact of the number
15 that's roughly about the amount of
hours I've been working today it's
actually closer to 16 I want to ask what
would you do if you were in your dad's
shoes and you didn't come to the US
until you were 23 you know I wanna I
want to believe that if I came to the
u.s. in the way that my dad did which
was not only a 23 years old but also
with a child and another one on the way
that I would do the same thing that he
did which was completely work his face
off to allow the next generation to kind
of build on top of that and so you know
I don't think I would have done anything
different um yeah I think a lot of its
circumstance my dad had a great uncle
who had a liquor store that he got to
work in that great uncle passed away and
it was just all these kind of different
variables I think circumstance has a lot
to do with what I would have done but
the one thing I know I would have done
is work every hour of every day Tommy
asks 13 thoughts of being an
entrepreneur you say you focus on top
line versus bottom up why tell me you
know one thing I think a lot of
entrepreneurs do special ones that are
just starting company since I invest in
so many of them that completely blows me
away they start looking to drive margin
profit very early on the reason I always
focus on top-line revenue and something
I did in my dad's business and something
that AJ felt when I started going full
time on the Boehner front was you can
always drive your profits higher
eventually but when you got a moment in
time and when I run businesses I tend to
innovate and I tend to be slightly ahead
of the market and and the market
eventually catches up to me and then
that's the good thing that's the moment
when it's exciting people start
believing in social media
we're believing in internet e-commerce
wine businesses or we're believing in
Australia New Zealand South African wine
I have to really run fast and grab as
many customers because I'm slightly
ahead then three four five six seven
eight years down the line I can start
driving profit you can always start
cutting costs raising prices at any time
but land grabbing more customers gives
you leverage of the scale that you'll -
I need to convert that and so I think
people go in for the the right hook the
peripheral the big right hook a lot of
times way too early sometimes to appease
investors sometimes because they just
want to start buying boats and Rolexes
and I just uh you know I'm just kind of
pushing and building leverage for the
long term hey Gary
John Lee Dumas entrepreneur on fire here
and I've a hashtag askgaryvee question
Pareto's law states that 80% of our
desired outcomes come from just 20% of
our activities do you agree with this if
so what's your 20 that's a great
question I think a lot of people have
brought that up I know a lot of people
in our organization believe in that I
put a lot of people believe in that you
know do I believe in that and what is my
twin John first of all congrats on your
podcast
um you know I I probably think weirdly
enough that it might even be more
extreme there is a big part of me that
thinks it's probably closer to 98 and -
then there's another part of me that
believes that it's - and 98 I am the
kind of person that doesn't give a crap
about other people's laws or principles
what feels right for me is execution I
think when people start knowing you know
this is kind of what I talk about my
naivete or lack of knowledge helps me I
think if I knew about this law prior to
you bringing it up I mean I've heard
about the 80/20 rule but I know your
official name if I knew about this law
it would actually make me want to play
within that law and then that would
probably take away from the strength
that I create every day I mean people
ask me what the ROI of the askgaryvee
show is a couple episodes ago new
Hardcore watches know that I say well
this is selling my fourth book here's
what I think I think human beings
overthink [ __ ] right and try to buy into
some sort
thisis read a book it makes me feel good
whether it's crush it or Peru doze law
or whatever it's called and I think that
is a fundamental problem I think when we
start coming from what's authentic and
what feels more natural you know the law
I believe in is that my mom and dad had
sex at a moment created me and I'm
taking this DNA to the finish line that
ball that's the law I believe Robert
asks I know viewers get a lot out of
your new show but what is the most
significant experience that you get out
of it
Robert that's a tremendous question I
appreciate it
you know for me I it's kind of weird
right I had this whole chapter of doing
video blogging on an everyday basis that
I enjoyed so much in it for
five-and-a-half years I think the best
thing I have is like being back in the
game a game that I love I mean I love
running businesses but doing this video
blogging thing it's just a lot of fun
for me the other thing that really I get
a lot out of it a lot of you hardcore
old schoolers remember Mott and those
kind of things I mean Dean Rock show
this show Andy and there's Zak and Joe
stunwin and and here we are in by the
way and d-roc he loves it like all clean
show the table D Ronnie he like was like
scared that you guys would be like uh
admins he's a little polished for me at
times but like the biggest thing I get
is that here I'm in Atlantic City by the
way a little fun fact real quick
pre-show to this Sunday night's Miss
America from eight to nine I think I'm
getting a lot of like action so make
sure you DVR that and check that out but
here I am in Atlantic City what would be
going on right now I would be sleeping
or doing email but here I'm jamming
there's kind of like team like family
thing I love that so much I'm creating
something creating something is special
and so I appreciate you guys caring
enough at enough scale to make me want
to continue to do this and build
something them there's a there's no
substitute for the feeling of
accomplishing something and that's what
I feel is happening here so thanks so
much uh thanks for watching this episode
question of the day this is very simple
I'm keeping it basic keeping it very
basic what state do you live in you keep
asking questions
I will keep trying to answer